violence surging in cities a new video
shows criminals acting more brazen than
ever
in new york city a man brutally
sucker-punched a 55-year-old asian woman
is sickening she's now reportedly in
stable condition
the suspect chart was apparently
arrested eight times
in the past year eight times in san
francisco a police officer was pummeled
by a homeless man
until bystanders stepped in to help her
so harold you live you live in new york
a few blocks from me i see you all the
time
uh you should wear more clothes when you
jog though
okay keep that in between i'm sorry so
this guy was arrested actually 17 times
he's homeless eight times in the past
year
you live here what do you think we know
there's a spike in crime
but these crimes are very similar
they're not even linked to
they're not even linked to theft they're
just these is
what do you think that what do you think
is the real problem here
well we got to stop it we need to we
need not to defund the police we need to
put as much as we can in police
departments across the country i think
it's naive to think that you can't hold
police accountable and fund the police
we should do both too
i think there's a mental health issue
we've got to address and i think that
one aspect of the defunded police
conversation it gets caught up we
think badly about it because we talk
about the funding police but we got to
think about mental health and
what the police do whether or not we
have a different force or force within
the force
to deal with that also have some
concerns around bell reform i think it
was well-intentioned but i'm not
convinced
that we're getting after we're solving
the problem that we want to solve in
fact we may be
we we may be have we may have
overreached here that doesn't mean we
shouldn't go back and look at it and try
to get it right but what we have now is
not working
and kids moms and dads uh people in
every community should feel safe walking
outside of their
door it is it's vegan it's a cr it's
just
a it's a creepy atmosphere it's like you
because it's you the people that you see
committing these ads are not
well and my theory is that they
are they when they look at shelters
there's not a place for them
they're not going to the shelters and
they're being spun out of prison they
don't care
because they just go back into jail and
maybe jail is preferable to the shelters
there's not there's we gave 800 million
dollars
to de blasio's wife to do this thrive
thing
that should have solved more than this
and nothing has happened
no that was a boondoggle like you could
have thrown that money
down in an open manhole in new york city
part of the problem is and i'm not don't
mean to disparage police
but with people who are mentally ill
i've seen people
i'm not someone rubbing human excrement
on the outside of say a cvs they're not
going to arrest that individual
because with this this man who who
assaulted this asian woman he's been
arrested 40 times so
under bail reform every time you get
picked up you aren't held
there's no bail you're right back out on
the street and then the crimes aren't
prosecuted
if they pick up somebody who's mentally
ill that individual might go to say
bellevue hospital for 72 hours
there has been a vast
de-institutionalization of the mentally
ill
since jfk quite frankly and it's only
gotten worse and that means there's not
a lot of help for people who really need
it number one number two just
quickly to watch the mayoral primary
that's coming up june 22nd
eric adams former retired police captain
captain strong on police but
catherine garcia who's been backed by
the new york times
she says officers who did not wear masks
during last year's protest have to be
docked their pay
that's her stance on cops oh oh good
jesse this is oh this is new york but
we're seeing lots of stuff all over the
country um but
we're not seeing much of it in the
suburbs so is this just something that
only the city people are dealing with
and and is it covert related
it is so thanks for bringing us back to
the city greg yeah we really appreciate
that
but there's a judge out there who stared
in the eyeballs
of this deranged lunatic looked at his
rap sheet
right and slammed the gavel down and
probably said probation
yeah and didn't sentence the guy there's
a bad judge out there that could have
thrown the book at this guy
and didn't and back in the day i would
have been at the judge's doorstep
at six a.m and stuck a mic in his face
because he's a villain
and you have to humiliate these judges
in order them to get tougher
because without a judge that gets tough
you're going to keep
rolling out these perps and they're
going to keep committing crimes
the deinstitutionalization situation
liberals love institutionalizing someone
that
fires off a gun they're ready to go to
court the next day have the gun seized
have all their constitutional rights
taken away from them
but you can have some lunatic out there
and sock someone push them in front of
the train
and then the next day they're out on the
streets again you need to
institutionalize these people because
they're sick
i'll make this one final point and you
can tie this back to our discussion on
the economy
and you look at what's happening in some
of these blue states with the defund the
police movement or slashing police
budgets and you look at the
spike and rise in crime and then you see
video like that that just makes your
heart hurt
thank god we're hearing she's in stable
condition that woman but
and how do you expect to return full
workforce
to a city like new york when you see
these random
awful attacks happening on cities
i mean i for anybody walking down a
block in new york right now i don't feel
safe
there's i mean this could happen to
anyone anywhere at any moment
i think the thing that is so shocking
about this modern type of violence
is that it's the victims like who hits
an old lady
that's in the back of your head that's
the thing it's like who hits an old lady
predators go for the
weakest yeah that's who they're
targeting but they're not they're not
even taking stuff from them
they're just pounding them and then it's
obviously the guy is psychotic he was on
special k
which is i don't know what kind of drug
that is well that's why harold's running
through the streets so fast
he's trying to get away from everybody
all right well i forget my clothes
he's got his socks though coming up hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else